if you hate somebody so bad in your
heart
before you pass on
that hate will go to you it will never
go to the person that you hate
and all the things that you um
bombarded the person people with
are the things that you're going to go
through that's how i feel
that um
is the difference between uh love and
hate
all right paulette yes paulette where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
um modesto california up north
modesto and tell me about your childhood
you had both your parents when you were
young
i had my mother and my father he passed
away when i was four and a half years
old
um my mom didn't pass away until
she was um in her 70s
of alzheimer's how was your childhood
um
at times it was really good and at times
it was super difficult
[Music]
um
because we weren't um looked after real
well
by your mom yeah
what was mom doing that distracted me
she was chasing an alcoholic
boyfriend
so when somebody needed help
in the family um
she wasn't available
but i understand she grew up knowing
what she knew
how to be and um
same as i grew up i grew up not knowing
anything
but i had to teach myself a lot of
things
would you describe your challenge it's
super difficult
i was a perfect student
i loved school because home life was
very difficult some of the children were
getting in troubles going to
[Music]
get locked up at different places
so i just blended in
where i was seen and not heard
what kind of kid were you in high school
pardon me what kind of kid were you in
high school
i was i excelled in everything
i was the person that taught
all the kids a lot of their knowledge
from the books
i a straight a student
and um
i didn't have very many boyfriends
you're lonely yeah i have to oh gosh
i talked oh wow um i'd have to say
that's
pretty pretty fair uh to say
i wrote a poem
in the sixth grade i think it was and it
was
pertaining to the word lonely
my lonely empty heart
and you went on your own and at what age
after after high school
um yes um 18 years old
i became responsible to um pay my
mother's
rent where she lived on the house she
buying the house
and i paid the rent
so she could have that house until she
was ready to sell it
because she had bought a motorhome a
mobile home with her
beyonce
do you have children
yes i have two sons
the oldest one is frank jr
he is um 40 years old
my youngest son is paul
and he is 30 he's sometimes
37 38 he's about two to three years
younger than frank can you raise them
oh yes i loved raising my children
they meant everything i mean everything
to me was that the best time of your
life
yes yes i chose like if i were to be
younger um my favorite year
would be 25 years old that's when i had
both my children
and um i did everything that i could
i doted on them i i took them places
i drove them crazy at christmas
i would take them to it was called
christmas tree lane
and um i would take them like if they
would go
every single night twice a night
i i just love christmas i there's
something that's so
happy for me i i don't know what it is
it's definitely for children i don't
have to have
presents for them just decorations
you know um and and that makes me
excited it brings back good memories
yeah
of your childhood yes uh yeah
my my favorite is when my dad took me
a christmas plane let's say
one year
i got everything i ever wanted then
and um
[Music]
it was incredible to me
i enjoyed it but your dad passed away
yes i was four and a half years old
four and a half but you remember your
father yes
yes um he was a very good looking man um
if i had a picture of him one picture
and he was a cook
um he looks he looks
like desi arnaz to me
so classy and
handsome and um steady
real steady person
so today you're living on skid row yes i
am how did that happen
um i left my fiance
of 13 years that's the same amount of
years i was married to my husband
i left him not because i didn't love him
it was because
he became very rageful to the point
um i felt and i told him
that he was killing my soul and i just i
just
uh couldn't take the pressure
that um i felt um
i loved my job i was great at what i did
but when i came home
everything was missing so um
it wasn't until i started working that i
really
could tell the difference between
paulette
and that man's
candy girl or whatever you want to call
it i was a lot younger than him
i let him do anything he wanted anytime
he wanted i never questioned anything i
never
became uh suspicious um
with my husband i was pretty bad about
um
not trusting and so i let this man
just be so trustworthy it was
very comfortable for me because i didn't
have to extra guess
anything and put extra things in my head
um
so when he was gone i would just be me
so there were trust issues in both those
relationships um
with my husband yes um i trusted the
second man to the degree that
um i knew not to trust him when he was
rageful and he became rageful uh
daily and i couldn't figure out if it
was his
job if it was something about him
personally
or he never wanted to get married
and that was okay with me i'm an open
person if that's
the person i love um
so um
i gave up asking the questions and i
felt like he had this tremendous guilt
that he couldn't share with me it was
like a
almost it was pretty effed up
to look on his face so i knew that he
had something
had to have something but i didn't uh
spend a lot of time trying to figure it
out
that's good that you got out huh yeah
that's good you got out
yeah because uh he did get me in the
garage once
i had a neck surgery got a plate in my
neck
and um he got me up in the garage and
picked me up by my neck
and the neighbor man came driving by
and immediately came over and uh
he dropped me like like quick
and you ended up homeless how um when i
left that man
i had really good credit um and i don't
know why
i didn't think to
use my money
to get my own place or my own
independence or anything like that
as it turns out um
i feel that it was the best thing that
ever happened my choice
number one i didn't put my children
through um
terrific hell um they did not know
uh my whereabouts my
youngest son found me uh probably not
about eight months ago
through a christian people group
and he asked that they searched for me
and they did and they found me in six
months
so i didn't want my children to have to
hear all these stories and secondhand
things that was going on with me
so i felt it best that i just
cut it off and i found out my youngest
son had been looking for me no matter
what
no matter what
for quite a few years and
because i am the mother that raised him
um i believe that um
he also felt that this mother that was
out here
on skid row could still be um
quite sufficient um
he's told me i don't know how many times
that he's proud of me
he's told me some cute little stories
about um
some things i shared with him about him
and myself and
and possibly his older brother
spiritual things and the way he told me
the stories were just like
i hear them here today
and i know that um
um
that he's here uh in spirit of course
mind soul body and spirit i don't know
being proud i've changed a lot
i'm very um
i say anything i want just about to
anybody
i pray a lot and that
certain things that people say and have
done
against me i have
with my spirit getting very stern
about my feelings of
the process that they must go through
like here's for instance if you hate
somebody so bad in your heart
before you pass on
that hate will go to you it will never
go to the person that you hate
and all the things that you um
bombarded the person people with are the
things that you're gonna go
through that's how i feel that um
is the difference between uh love and
hate
are drugs a part of your life yes um
i did do crack cocaine in the beginning
in the beginning of my usage i used for
about
14 years and
i don't feel that i used as many
people out there that are on drugs
in the beginning i did i went way
overboard but i learned how to
function and how to
think and still say prayers because no
matter what
the god of my understanding tells me
i take you as you are i will change the
things that i need to change
in you not them
there this began the drug use began
during your second relationship
after in 2005.
so when you when you became homeless
i started working the streets i mean
everything uh
i was suburbian how to grow up
in gangster life
because these are gangsters out here
they're hell raisers they're
brutal have you had bad things happen to
you here
oh yes a lot of things
and finally today i just look at them
and i say
if you're going to like hold me hostage
kill me
or whatever you think you want to do go
ahead because you're going to hell no
matter what
you will go to hell i don't pay the
price and i'm going to walk
away from you and i end up walking away
it's the darndest thing because uh i had
some guy stick me in a car
and hold me hostage and nobody could get
in this car
even though it was unlocked it was
unlocked
and um is because of the power of prayer
that i
acknowledge um that puts people at bay
they can't i don't care what they think
i hear women tell me they're gonna
whip my ass and take my [ __ ] go ahead if
they think they can
because my spiritual
persona tells me
they can't get that far from me anymore
they can't swing at me
they can't they could do other weird
stuff maybe
that i don't know how to um
change but i've learned um
by um
biting my way through i actually
am my own soldier basically
to uh
fight um
for what i represent
have you been raped or anything like
that yeah
pretty much every woman that's down here
has encountered that
and where do you sleep um i sleep
um in a tent i am changing
where i live today because there's been
some
strong things that have taken
a place between me and
it was supposed to be one person but it
turned out to be the entire neighborhood
so i'm not going to be participating in
negativity it's just not my style
it's not my style yeah good luck
avoiding that here
i do i just stay away and
um i say to the person
what i think is going on and
i don't care my spirit is so strong
i am so precise
it's incredible it's totally yourself
because you're in the heart of
i've had to grow up here and learn the
true life
as uncomfortable as it may make others
feel
i care about myself and i love myself
today
because of anything and everything that
took place in my past
it's made me who i am
and i love that a lot of people don't
like that are you happy
today yes on the most part
i'd have to really say yes
it's been a hard fight but it's also
been
i've had to question a lot of things and
when i talked to my son on the phone
i knew i knew
a lot of things were gonna get worked
out have your sons come to
try to take you out of here um he asked
me if i
if i he asked me if i wanted to
go to a program and recover and
i said no i'm not ready and now
today i can tell you i know what he was
talking about
um i've had to
reprogram
a lot of structure
around me so that i could
break through and um
so i can be me are you still using drugs
today
barely yes i use
[Music]
meth i quit
crack because this man a friend of mine
started using it
and it wasn't correct the way i knew
crack was supposed to be like i couldn't
get the inhalation
and the smoke i i it was like sucking
like
without getting anything not barely any
air
and i i quit instantly that was the best
thing
actually that happened i think i kind of
miss the
the feelings that i used to get i used
to actually
um i could hear angels constantly
and i know i wasn't hallucinating
because when i would stop
like when i went to jail and stuff i
could still hear them
this was on crack yeah and then off a
crack
i could still hear them and um
it's not that they sing or anything
it's like one voice talks to me but
several at the same time
how do you support yourself now um i'm
on
gr uh food stamps and um
i barely ever spend my food stamps on
drugs
i mean barely um
um i probably did 10 bucks all of six
months
um and i i have worked the streets
um i have calmed down on that because
i don't care for the street
owners of each street
they bombard me they try to get one
over on me and they try to use me
and i i don't play that game i stay away
from that territory
it's just you know used to be mine i
used to have it
like that because of the power of prayer
but now um
i get dates every now and then just men
driving in vehicles
wherever i'm walking it doesn't
make a difference you know it doesn't
have to be every day
and i use the money for things that i
want or need
it's usually um cigarettes or
food or
clothing or this time i want to radio
crystal meth you'll pay for how um
sometimes
um the men that i know have it
um want to have a favor so they share
with me some do some don't um
sometimes um there's just guys that
i meet and i'm very specific with them
that i'm not there to um
give pleasure i just want to get high
and that they don't want that
then i turn them down not a lot of guys
i trust
really um they tend to
get sneaky on you you know not all but
a lot of them and paula what's the most
important lesson you've learned
to trust in myself trust
in the path
that i am supposed to be in
trust in my thought process
and uh
[Applause]
don't trust in the hellions
that's just people that they think that
they're giving
getting up on over on me and i haven't
pegged
pretty much before they can even start
their engines
i i sometimes get scared
because uh sometimes i think i'm on um
you know the wrong path but i know i'm
on the right path i feel it i
i feel it super strong
off and on it stays that i feel so sad
and distraught
and then there's days that i feel like
we are moving
we are doing this thing yeah
it's wonderful all right call that well
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you and i wish you the best of
luck out there oh it's going to be
be careful oh yeah yeah
it's dangerous for a woman out there
right huh it's dangerous for a woman out
there
oh i know
thank you thank you